we've kind of been uh sneaking around it
but let me ask you from
yours
from everything we've been talking about
how do you think about consciousness
is it uh instead of
fun little trick that the human mind
does or is it somehow fundamental to
this whole thing
so uh this three pound lump of jelly
inside our craniums that can
contemplate
um the vastness of interstellar space it
can contemplate the meaning of infinity
and it can contemplate itself
contemplating on the meaning of infinity
that peculiar self-recursive quality
that we call
self-awareness so this is the hard
problem right this is this is uh the
unknowable the unknown at least yeah um
i don't know i have no good answer for
that aside from do you think it's
somehow
deeply fundamental to the human
experience or is it just a trick so you
have like
i mean samurais has really been making
me uh think about this so you know
calling free will and illusion
the interesting thing about sam is
it's not just a philosophical little
chat with him about free will
he really says he experiences
the lack of free will
like he's able to you know
large parts of the day to feel like he
has no free will
in that same way
now he thinks that consciousness
is um
not an illusion
it is you know it's a real thing but at
the same i'm more almost like
i'm almost more of like consciousness
seems to be a little bit of an illusion
in the sense that like it feels like
maybe this is a robotics ai perspective
but it feels like in that same way that
sam steps outside of
feeling like he has an agency
feeling like he has a free will i feel
like we should be able to step outside
of having a consciousness
so that that from my perspective maybe
that's a hopeful perspective for trying
to engineer consciousness but do you
think consciousness is like at the core
of this or is it just uh just like
language
or almost like a thing we build on top
of uh
much deeper human
the things that makes us human i don't
know i am attracted to lanza's notion of
biocentrism i mean it's difficult to
walk away from the double slit
experiment not wondering
why
we seem capable of collapsing that
quantum wave function it's very very
weird
giving rise to even weirder ideas about
superposition and spooky action at a
distance
and things that mit guys know a lot
better than me but um
it seems to me fundamental maybe
consciousness is is the fundamental
thing um i mean weirdly
some of these ancient incubatory
practices i talked about peter kingsley
before so he's not a proponent of
ancient psychedelic use but is a
proponent of these ancient rites of
incubation
that were practiced by pythagoras
parmenides and pedicles other
pre-socratics and so what were they
doing they were trying to get in touch
with consciousness they were entering
into suspended states of animation
um in these cave-like settings
pythagoras had built one in his basement
and would lie down motionless apparently
for long periods of time and what i
think they were trying to do
um was tap into and trying to answer
this question in their own you could
call it a scientific way actually less
religion than science
um and what they would
discover or try to discover was a state
of awareness that is somehow beyond life
and death beyond waking and dreaming
where you can be aware of the senses but
also in touch with another reality
at the exact same time what kingsley
calls sensation
that i think
is definitely worth exploring
well and the way i hope to explore is by
trying to build it but
everybody uses the tools they have well
no i do also hope psychedelics can help
so how do you build that i'm curious
that's a whole other discussion
this is uh
there's a lot of things i could say here
but let me put simply
is i believe
that
you can go
a long way
building
towards building consciousness
by trying to fake
consciousness
so fake it till you make it
as an engineering approach i think will
work for consciousness
you seem satisfied with that i i'm
satisfied with that because i know how
deeply unsatisfied others are
but just wait
so
i mean i don't know what to so most most
the the the topic of consciousness is
mostly handled by philosophers currently
and
that's great uh and their
uh philosophers are wonderful and good
at what they do i'm not a philosopher
i'm an engineer and i think the approach
there is quite different
i think
falling in love is different
than trying to have a podcast
conversation about what is love
uh
you know i i i think the engineering
effort is just fundamentally different
than the philosophical effort
and i
have a sense that consciousness can be
engineered
even before it is understood by the
philosophers so i think there's a bunch
of things like that in this world that
could be engineered before they're
understood i think the intelligence is
one such thing i think we'll be we'll
we'll be able to engineer
super intelligent beings before we're
able to understand the human mind
that's
um
yeah i mean
there's less there's a lot of intuition
to unpack there of why that is but um
as it stands
that's perhaps my engineering
uh
optimism and engineering ethic under
which i operate
consciousness is easy to build hard to
understand
okay
you